mais mais mes chers collègues
on va on va peut-être débuter mes chers
collègues et on va peut-être fermer la
porte mes chers collègues je suis
heureux d'accueillir ce matin Monsieur
Bernard romand ancien président de
l'Autorité de régulation des transports
alors qu'à ce jour aucun candidat à la
présidence de cette autorité publique
indépendante n'a été proposée par le
Président de la République depuis le
retrait de la candidature de Marc
papinetti en février dernier et que la
RT n'a donc pas de président depuis août
2022 date depuis laquelle Monsieur
Philippe Richard a ce intérim il nous
semble important de vous entendre
et je vous remercie d'avoir accepté
notre invitation nous avons bien
conscience que vous ne portez plus de
parole officielles puisque on est plus
en fonction
néanmoins néanmoins je pense pouvoir
dire que vous avez dans votre précédente
fonction fait preuve de courage
d'indépendance et de francs parler sur
des sujets particulièrement complexes
c'est pourquoi alors où sont évoqués de
nouveaux projets d'infrastructures de
nouveaux modèles de financement et de
nouveaux textes relatifs au secteur des
transports votre retour d'expérience à
la tête de la RT nous intéresse tout
particulièrement d'autant que sous votre
présidente le régulateur des Transports
a vu son périmètre et ses prérogatives
considérablement s'élargir alors qu'en
2016 au début de votre mandat l'autorité
qui s'est d'abord appelée la RAF puis la
raffaire avait en pratique vocation à
réguler le secteur du ferroviaire son
champ d'action c'est progressivement
élargi aux autocars au secteur
aéroportuaire et autoroutier ainsi
qu'aux transports publics urbain en
Île-de-France et au service numérique de
mobilité aussi à la lumière de ces
évolutions pourriez-vous monsieur le
Président dressé le bilan de vos six
années passées à la tête de l'autorité
et de sa montée en puissance
et en vue de l'audition que l'on espère
prochaine d'un nouveau candidat quels
sont d'après vous les qualités
indispensables du futur président de la
RT
par ailleurs estimez-vous que les moyens
de la RT ils sont suffisants pour faire
face à la l'ensemble de ces missions
notre commission sur la proposition de
ces rapporteurs pour avis sur le projet
de loi de finances c'est plusieurs fois
prononcé en faveur d'une augmentation de
la subvention pour charge de service
public de l'autorité étant entendu
qu'elle a été contrainte ces dernières
années de solliciter son fond de
roulement faut d'augmentation de sa
subvention
ne nous inquiétons notamment de ce que
la RT dispose de marges de manœuvre
suffisantes en cas de contentieux
ce constat est-il d'après vous toujours
d'actualité la RT dispose-t-elle
toujours des moyens de son indépendance
ce sujet est d'une importance cruciale
notamment dans le contexte de
l'ouverture à la concurrence du
transport ferroviaire national des
voyageurs avoir un régulateur fort
régulateur indépendant et d'ailleurs
l'une des conditions de la réussite de
l'ouverture à la concurrence
parallèlement à l'extension de son champ
d'action la RT a en effet pris une place
croissante dans le paysage
institutionnel et c'est sa vie ses
rapports ses décisions sont souvent très
attendues ils jouent un rôle crucial et
constitue une forme du jurisprudence
pour telle ou telle secteur
pour ne donner qu'un exemple à décision
du 28 février 2020 portant en règlement
du différent entre la région
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur et SNCF
voyageurs a permis de définir un cadre
méthodologique sur la détermination du
nombre d'emplois devant être transférés
dans le cadre de l'ouverture à la
concurrence des services conventionnés
c'est les gars je souhaiterais connaître
votre appréciation sur le déroulement de
l'ouverture de la concurrence du
transport ferroviaire nous avions
entendu il y a un peu plus d'un an
lorsque le nouveau contrat de
performance entre SNCF réseau et l'État
a été rendu public vous n'aviez
d'ailleurs pas manqué d'évoquer à cette
occasion un certain nombre de
difficultés qui demeuraient
j'en viens à présent un sujet qui
suscite vif intérêt de la part des
membres de nos de notre commission
celui de l'avenir des concessions
autoroutières
nous avons engagé la semaine dernière
ainsi que d'audition sur le sujet
en entendant le président et le
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale sur le contrôle de la
régulation de l'évolution des
concessions autoroutières ainsi que les
dirigeants de Vinci Autoroutes et de
Seneffe nous entendrons également après
votre audition Philippe Noury président
d'ap2r depuis l'élargissement des
compétences de la RT au secteur
autoroutier l'autorité a permis de
conseiller l'état
concédant dans ses négociations avec les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute et
permis de réguler les tarifs de péage
pour un bénéfice économique direct aux
usagers d'après le rapport 6 ans de
régulation des transports publiée à la
fin de votre mandat les recommandations
de la RT se sont traduites par une
réduction effective de 290 millions
d'euros des péages
nous avons bien évidemment l'intention
d'entendre la RT qui a publié en janvier
dernier son deuxième rapport sur
l'économie des concessions autoroutières
néanmoins la lumière de votre expérience
qu'elle regarde portez-vous sur ses
relations entre l'État et les SCA est
considérez-vous comme des équilibré la
question de la rentabilité est plus
particulièrement de la méthodologie de
du calcul de la rentabilité est assez
dégâts crucial
enfin comment comment après rendez-vous
la fin des concessions autoroutières
qu'elle regarde portez-vous sur les
dernières annonces gouvernementales
relatives au secteur autoroutier la
première ministre alors de la
présentation d'un plan d'avenir pour les
transports esquisser une piste
est-ce qui sait la piste d'une plus
importante contribution du secteur
autoroutier Bruno Le Maire a quant à lui
indiqué la semaine dernière avoir saisi
le conseiller d'État quant à la
possibilité de raccourcir de quelques
années la durée de certains conditions
se pose également la question de
l'avenir des péages
consubstantielle à celle de la fin des
concessions quel regard portez-vous sur
cette problématique je ne serai pas plus
long et je vous cède dès à présent la
parole pour une durée d'une vingtaine de
minutes au maximum je précise que nous
avons comme la semaine dernière fait le
choix d'entendre un grand nombre
d'acteurs la question des autorités en
particulier et qui a pour conséquence de
limiter la durée maximale de chacune des
auditions je vous demanderai donc de
respecter ce temps de parole monsieur le
Président je vous donne je vous souhaite
la parole merci monsieur le Président
cher Jean-François Longeot
d'abord merci de m'avoir invité j'ai
accepté avec plaisir même si comme vous
l'avez dit je n'ai plus aucune fonction
officielle et donc
ma parole n'engage
aucunement la RT
elle n'engage que moi elle ne sera pas
donc officielle elle sera peut-être un
peu plus libre de ce fait
donc merci merci de cette audition on
m'avait dit 10 minutes d'intervention
liminaire vous me dites 20
c'est une
une proposition que j'entends avec
plaisir puisque j'ai toujours du mal à
tenir le le temps qui m'est imparti
quel bilan je tire de de six ans de
président de cette autorité comme
chacune et chacun d'entre vous j'ai été
par le Nanterre et je regardais les
autorités indépendantes avec beaucoup de
suspicion en me disant en permanence
mais au nom de quel légitimité
prennent-ils des décisions aussi lourdes
j'oubliais quand j'étais parlementaire
que c'est le Parlement qui a créé la RAF
il l'a transformé en arts à faire puis
en aerté et que c'est le Parlement qui
lui a donné non seulement un certain
nombre de missions mais aussi un certain
nombre de pouvoirs et des pouvoirs qui
sont loin d'être négligeables
et je me suis souvenu quand je suis
devenu président de la RT que c'était
effectivement le Parlement qui avait
fait la RT qui lui avait donné ses
pouvoirs et donc il était indispensable
de rendre des comptes au Parlement et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
souvent venu devant votre commission je
vous ai
adressé fait adresser l'ensemble de la
documentation des
publications de la RT et je n'ai pas
manqué de saisir vous-même chers
président mais vos prédécesseurs aussi
votre prédécesseur aussi des
problématiques nous rencontrions sur la
question des transports je n'ai jamais
rendu compte à l'exécutif ni au
président de la République ni au
ministre je n'ai rendu compte qu'au
Parlement et je crois que c'est
important que vous le sachiez
alors que vous allez être appelé dans
les j'espère les semaines qui viennent à
vous prononcer sur la proposition d'un
président de l'Autorité des transports
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
sur ce bilan c'est que
j'ai très vite compris que
naturellement la RAF en 2009 avait été
créé par transposition d'une directive
européenne qui voulait que dans le cadre
de l'ouverture du marché du rail il
fallait une autorité indépendante qui
garantissent
un accès équitable transparent non
discriminatoire à l'infrastructure
c'était la même problématique que celle
qu'on avait connue pour l'énergie la
même problématique que celle qu'on avait
connue sur les télécoms France Télécom
pour les télécoms c'était la grande
entreprise qui à la fois géré le réseau
et le service
EDF qui gérait le réseau et le service
et puis la SNCF qui gérait le réseau et
le service il se trouvait que pour la
SNCF vous allez
séparer le réseau du service pour que
d'autres concurrents puissent avoir
accès à ce réseau ouverture à la
concurrence et il fallait qu'il y ait
une autorité indépendante qui puisse
veiller à ce caractère non
discriminatoire transparent de l'accès
au réseau
j'évite compris que au-delà de cette
transposition de ces transpositions
puisqu'il y a eu des transpositions sur
d'autres secteurs les aéroports
directives européennes là aussi
la RATP même principe la RATP à la fois
le réseau et le service et en 2039 c'est
très loin mais sur le Grand Paris c'est
avant en 2039 il y aura l'ouverture à la
concurrence sur le métro il fallait
séparer donc la gestion du réseau de la
gestion du service
ça c'était des transpositions
européennes les
les données numériques de la mobilité
aussi mais il y a des secteurs sur
lesquels
les pouvoirs que vous avez donné à la RT
n'ont rien à voir avec les directives
européennes et c'est notamment les
concessions autoroutières et c'est un
sujet qui vous préoccupe comment sont
venus les questions liées aux
compétences données par le Parlement à
la raffaire à l'époque est devenu la RT
au concession autoroutière
un rapport de l'Autorité de la
concurrence de la Cour des comptes 2014
qui
stigmatise
les les
profits considérables
je mets le terme entre guillemets des
sociétés autoroutières
grosses et moi à l'époque la ministre
des Transports
décident du gel des péages c'était
Ségolène Royal et
la loi Macron 2015 dit il faut
réduire les inégalités de de pouvoir
entre l'État concédant et les sociétés
concessionnaires il faut donc un
régulateur qui puisse rééquilibrer le
rapport de force et c'est là que on a
donné à la RT des pouvoirs dans le
domaine autoroutier sur
non pas
la régulation des péages comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président mais
sur
les
péages et la régulation des péages est
décalée dans les contrats
était calé dans les contrats je veux y
insister pas seulement depuis la
primaire privatisation mais depuis
l'origine des sociétés d'autoroute quand
les sociétés d'autoroute ont été
privatisées 90% des
réseaux autoroutier en 2006
le les clauses d'évolution des péages et
70% de l'inflation plus les opérations
nouvelles
sont restés les mêmes que celles qui
existait auparavant et donc
ça n'est pas
ce travail que nous faisons puisque les
contractuels mais par contre chaque fois
que des avenants sont proposés
il appartient à la RT de donner un avis
à chaque fois que des Atlantes sont
proposées qu'ils ont une incidence ou
sur la durée des concessions ou sur
l'augmentation des péages la RT
consultée pour donner un avis sur ses
avenants c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est on a demandé à la
RT à refaire à l'époque devenue à RT de
faire chaque année un rapport sur la
situation économique et financière de
toutes les sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroute
et troisième point on a demandé à la RT
c'est un point sur lequel je reviendrai
de mesurer
tous les 5 ans et tous les cinq ans ça
n'était pas un hasard le tri le
taux de rentabilité interne des sociétés
conceptionnelles de route ce que nous
avons fait une première fois en 2020 et
ce que nous avons recommencé un an et
demi plus tard et pas en attendant 5 ans
pourquoi pour éclairer le débat sur la
fin des concessions d'autoroute 2031
2036 et permettre aux décideurs publics
d'avoir un certain nombre d'éléments
pour pouvoir appréhender cette période
je retiens et je m'arrêterai là puis je
vis direct quelques mots sur les
autoroutes je retiens
une chose qui est essentielle de mon
passage à la présidence de la RT
c'est qu'il faut
un président et donc un collège qui soit
totalement indépendant
s'il y a
nous avons un certain nombre de valeurs
pivot à la RT que nous avons mise noir
sur blanc dans une forme de charte
le dialogue
l'expertise la transparence et
l'indépendance quatre pivots mais s'il
ne devait en rester qu'un c'est
l'indépendance
moi je veux vous donner la démonstration
de l'indépendance qui a été la mienne
moi j'ai eu à donner un avis sur deux
contrats de performance un sous la
présidence de François Hollande un sous
la présidence d'Emmanuel Macron
un avec un ministre des Transports qui
s'appelait Alain vidalis un avec un
ministre des Transports qui s'appelait
c'était pas encore Clément bonne c'était
Jean-Baptiste Dieu Barry
je suis venu vous présenter mon point de
vue sur ces deux contrats de performance
il mon avis a été extrêmement sévère
extrêmement sévère et je suis très très
heureux d'avoir connu post mortem un
plan de 100 milliards d'investissements
dans les transports qui a été annoncé il
y a quelques mois par la première
ministre qui finalement aurait été
annoncé il y a sept ans où il y a un an
si on avait suivi la vie de la RT sur
les contrats de performance sur les deux
contrats de performance qui ont été qui
ont été adoptés
c'est une démonstration de
l'indépendance qui est indispensable au
à la RT à son président et à son collège
vous me demandiez chez le président de
donner une ou deux illustrations de ce
que ce que ce qu'a fait la RT
je donne allez deux chiffres de trois
chiffres
et je n'ai je me suis pas appuyé sur les
services qui ne sont plus les miens pour
vous les donner mais c'est vrai que sur
les avenants des sociétés d'autoroute
nous avons examiné 17 avenants c'est
beaucoup mais ça s'explique j'y
reviendrai aussi par le fait que les
contrats plus les contrats de concession
sont longs plus naturellement il y a
d'avenants et la grande difficulté quand
il y a un avenant c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de concurrence et donc quand il n'y a
pas un régulateur qui regarde
précisément si dans la négociation de
gré à gré entre le conséquent et le
concessionnaire il n'y a pas de d'avu
ce n'est pas réglo
sur ces avenants sur 17 avenants la RT a
proposé
ces 17 avenants c'était un peu plus de 2
milliards d'euros
la RT en examinant les choses à proposer
une baisse de 800 millions le considant
a finalement retenu 300 millions un
petit 300 millions
c'est beaucoup parce que ces 300
millions en moins payés par les usagers
des péages
c'est peu si on considère qu'on avait
proposé 800 millions mais si on n'avait
pas proposé nos 800 millions c'est ça
aurait été zéro
chose qu'on oublie aussi on a des avis à
donner sur les sous concessions les sous
concessions c'est les aires d'autoroute
et sur les aires d'autoroute on a un mot
à dire sur la modération tarifaire du
carburant ça n'est pas neutre en ce
moment sur la modération tarifaire des
carburants sur l'ensemble des avis qui
ont été donnés pendant ma présidence
c'est un peu plus de 200 millions
d'euros qu'on a fait économiser aux
usagers de des sociétés d'autoroute et
si je vais vous donner un dernier
chiffre je le prends sur le domaine
aéroportuaire où on a donné nos un avis
conforme celui-là sur les tarifications
des redevances aéroportuaires on a fait
économiser 48 millions d'euros
aux sociétés de transport aux compagnies
aériennes qui se répercutent
naturellement sur les usagers bon voilà
d'autres
d'autres illustrations vous avez évoqué
la décision qu'on a pris sur le
règlement de différents Bouches-du-Rhône
sur l'ouverture à la concurrence du
ferroviaire sur un lot c'est très
important j'en dis un mot ouverture à la
concurrence du ferroviaire
le Transdev gagne un des deux lots
ouverts par la région Provence-Alpes
d'Azur mais dans le cahier des charges
il fallait mettre le personnel quel est
le personnel nécessaire la SNCF donne un
chiffre
la région le conteste
c'est la RT qui part la loi est chargé
d'arbitrer la RT arbitre est dit c'est
-30% de ce que de ce qu'annonce la SNCF
finalement cours d'appel de Paris est
saisi par la SNCF qui conteste la
décision de la RT et la cour d'appel dit
c'est moins 25%. c'est à dire c'était
plus -30% mais moins
25%. pourquoi je dis ça
parce qu'on se rend compte dans le cadre
de l'ouverture à la concurrence qu'il y
a des marges de progression qui existent
chez l'opérateur historique sur la
performance et je le dis
vous connaissez mon engagement
politique préalable à la présidence de
la RT il n'a pas changé sur le fond
je ne suis pas un libéral effréné
mais la performance dans une entreprise
de service public et une
et quelque chose qu'il faut rechercher
parce qu'une performance elle bénéficie
à l'usager et donc je crois que c'est
très important de montrer mais les
présidents successives de la SNCF
pépit et Pharaon doux en ont bien
conscience que cette performance est
quelque chose d'important
je pourrais vous dire encore bien
d'autres choses mais
indépendance indépendance indépendance
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel et
l'indépendance permet un dialogue
constructif avec chacun moi je n'ai j'ai
beaucoup dialogué avec les présidents
des sociétés d'autoroute que vous
retenez avec le ministre des Transports
avec les le Parlement naturellement pour
essayer de construire une régulation qui
soit la plus performante possible
j'en viens aux autoroutes
pour vous dire que il y a un sujet qui
focalise aujourd'hui
cette question des autoroutes qui me
semble et je le regrette non pas être la
fin des sociétés des concessions
d'autoroute mais faut-il oui ou non
demander aux sociétés d'autoroute de
finalement doit-on renationaliser avant
le terme des sociétés d'autoroute parce
que si on met fin
au contrat avant le terme des contrats
c'est une nationalisation sans le dire
alors moi je vais vous dire je reprends
complètement ma liberté de ce point de
vue là
mais je l'avais je vous l'avais dit
d'emblée
je ne suis pas là pour défendre les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
mais je constate
que la France à 110
le réseau d'autoroute le plus moderne le
plus performant le plus secure qui
existe au monde qui existe au monde et
que quand on fait la comparaison dans
notre pays entre l'état du réseau
autoroutier et routier national et le
l'état du réseau autoroutier concédé il
n'y a pas photo il y a pas photo et ça
c'est un fait
c'est sans doute lié au fait que les
sociétés d'autoroute par le fait de la
concession ont eu des ressources
qu'elles ont pu
affecter intégralement à leur compte
d'exploitation et donc y mettre dans
l'entretien du réseau de l'argent que
l'État devait mettre dans son propre
réseau par la fiscalité ça c'est sûr
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
pas le système concessif qui est à
condamné
c'est la façon dont les contrats ont été
écrits
écrit surtout écrit parce que une fois
que les contrats sont écrits la gestion
des contrats elle ne peut pas s'écarter
du droit et donc il n'y a pas beaucoup
de
discussions une fois que les contrastes
sont en cours et deuxième deuxième
élément
lorsqu'on a des contrats qui sont de 40
50 60 ans sur des concessions
autoroutières naturellement on est lié
avec un transfert du risque qui s'est
fait essentiellement sur les
concessionnaires et donc un risque qui
peut peser positivement ou négativement
je prends déclaration de Bruno Le Maire
récemment si
le tri actionnaire a autant augmenté ces
dernières années c'est bien parce que
les conditions du marché financier n'ont
pas été celle qui avait été prévue en
2006 et ont été beaucoup plus favorables
aux actionnaires qu'elle ne leur ait été
si
l'inflation permet aujourd'hui aux
sociétés concessionnaires
d'avoir plus de recettes plus 4,8%
d'augmentation des péages liés aux 70%
d'inflation d'avoir plus de recettes que
de dépenses c'est vrai mais si ça avait
été le contraire on aurait été dans la
difficulté si l'impôt sur les sociétés a
diminué
ces dernières années y compris pour les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
elles en ont bénéficié mais si le
gouvernement avait décidé d'augmenter
l'impôt sur les sociétés un autre
gouvernement
les sociétés concessionnelles n'auraient
pas été avantagé par rapport aux
conditions dans laquelle elle avait
signé le contrat puisqu'il n'y avait
rien dans le contrat qui disait
en cas d'augmentation des impôts vous
plairez moins ou en cas de diminution
des impôts vous paierez plus donc il
faut bien voir que la longueur des
contrats le transfert du risque sur les
sociétés concessionnaires nous place
trop en position de spectateurs de
l'évolution des choses
deuxième élément que je veux évoquer
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la
rentabilité
si vous permettez je dis deux choses je
dis deux choses
le chiffre
ignfc gedd et je n'ai pas lu le rapport
complètement j'ai lu les extraits qui
ont été publiés
parlent de la rentabilité actionnaire
on ne sait pas dans quelle temporalité
mais ça veut dire que quand il y a une
privatisation il y a des actionnaires et
il y a des créanciers il y a des
actionnaires qui achètent des actions il
y a de la dette qui est prise
généralement qui est prise pour la durée
des contrats
ce que l'IGF CGEDD pointe du doigt c'est
la rentabilité actionnaire
le travail qui a été fait par la RT qui
continue à être fait par la RT c'est la
rentabilité des projets ça veut dire
qu'on prend en compte à la fois les
apports des actionnaires l'apport des
créanciers la dette et on s'inscrit dans
la durée de la concession c'est à dire
qu'on prend pas à date la rentabilité
mais on se dit avec les investissements
qui restent à faire avec dans la durée
quel est le tri c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous noter notre théorie tel
qu'il a été
présenté et saluer y compris par les
instances académiques qui travaillent
sur ces questions
étaient au niveau que que vous
connaissez entre 6 et quelque chose et
7,6%
c'est-à-dire assez proche des prévisions
qui fait celle du contrat
le maire du Conseil d'État tranchera ce
serait bien que le Conseil d'État et
tous les éléments pour trancher et
d'ailleurs c'est pas moi qui le dis
c'est l'ancien président de la section
des travaux publics du Conseil d'État
qui l'a dit devant la commission
d'enquête sénatoriale qu'il voulait pour
que le Conseil d'État puisse se
prononcer qu'une autorité indépendante
je reprends ces termes puissent fournir
une étude
avec l'ensemble des éléments la durée
les créanciers la dette pour pouvoir
délibérer de la même manière la plus
claire qui soit je sais pas si Bruno Le
Maire a lu les déclarations
de Philippe Martin à l'époque devant la
commission mais il serait bien inspiré
et je ne je ne comprends pas je vous le
dis je suis très préoccupé de cette
qu'on puisse envisager de saisir le
Conseil d'État sans fournir au Conseil
d'État cette étude indépendante
et qu'on puisse traiter la question des
autoroutes sont demandées à l'instance
indépendante qui a été mise en place par
le Parlement par le Parlement de fournir
les éléments que le Parlement lui a
confié d'étudier ça je suis vraiment
choqué et en difficulté sur cette
question et c'est la dernière chose que
je veux dire
deuxième message dernier message que je
veux vous passer
je me suis efforcé pendant six ans
d'avoir un dialogue constructif avec le
gouvernement
on a même mis en place un dispositif
d'évaluation des coûts des opérations
avec Monsieur Jabari on a publié le
deuxième rapport c'est pas moi qui l'ai
publié c'est Philippe Richard sur les
concessions d'autoroute pour préparer
justement le sommet des autoroutes qui
étaient prévues à l'époque
aujourd'hui je vois que
l'autorité est obligée de s'auto saisir
sur un contrat de concession qui est
financé sur des indus comme si les indus
n'étaient pas des péages qui avaient été
perçues par les sociétés d'autoroute et
comme si ça n'entrait pas dans l'esprit
de ce qu'elle souhaitait le le
législateur en donnant une mission à la
RT de contrôler les avenants
parce que le gouvernement de la saisie
pas est publie le décret
je vois que le ministre des Transports
fait une déclaration un article une
interview dans laquelle il prévoit un
nouveau sommet des autoroutes avec des
parlementaires c'est formidable des ONG
les sociétés concessionnaires et la RT
n'existe pas qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
sans alerter c'est comme si on faisait
une mayonnaise sans y mettre l’œuf
je suis vraiment non mais je suis
en étant plus concerné mais en étant
m'excuserez averti je suis
très perplexe devant ce qui me semble
être une volonté de mettre côté une
autorité indépendante qui a démontré son
expertise même si son expertise gêne
quelquefois le gouvernement mais on est
aussi là pour ça quand il s'agit de dire
les choses donc voilà Président vous
voyez même la minute merci merci
mais c'était fort intéressant et
je pense que ça a beaucoup effectivement
capter l'attention de de mes collègues
je vais donner la parole à Michel
Dagbert
merci pour cette exposé monsieur
président romans
vous avez en quelque sorte dans ce
propos liminaire répondu déjà à pas mal
d'interrogations et notamment sur
l'aspect des contrats des sociétés
d'autoroute les consultations qui qui
s'ouvrent sur ce nouveau modèle de
financement qu'appelle de ses vœux le
ministre des Transports et à vocation à
permettre le financement et la mise à
niveau d'infrastructure ferroviaire en
utilisant
les
les profits
que je ne vais pas qualifier mais les
profits que l'on a constaté à l'issue de
l'examen et des rapports que vous venez
de mentionner sur les concessions
autoroutières à l'issue de votre mandat
vous aviez également dessiner quelques
perspectives et demander une réflexion
plus approfondie sur la façon dont
l'autorité pourrait elle-même contribuer
à la transition écologique pourriez-vous
nous préciser ce point et nous donner
votre position sur les modalités de la
contribution financière que pourrait
apporter les concessionnaires dans le
cadre des contrats repensés si nous
allions dans cette voie avec bien sûr la
problématique environnementale prégnante
que nous connaissons et donc par
conséquent je souhaitais vous entendre
sur ce point
merci je vais donner la parole à Gérard
Laennec
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
merci pour cette exposition
et permettez moi tout d'abord de vous
dire que la qualité de l'exposé a eu
pour effet de renforcer mes doutes et
mes questionnements
donc c'est déjà pas mal
évidemment qu'il y a un lien étroit
entre durée des contrats investissements
je ne développe pas
l'écriture des contrats c'est quelque
chose d'absolument déterminant je
partage aussi
il n'y a pas de clause de redevance
variable dans les contrats en question
donc par conséquent ce sont pas des
contrats très mobiles si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi
et
nous sommes confrontés à mon avis à une
situation assez complexe et ma question
est la suivante peut-on attendre 2031
alors que les exigences d'investissement
notamment pour la décarbonation des
mobilités frappe à la porte
donc c'est un c'est un vrai
questionnement et objectif
moi je remarque au passage c'est-à-dire
que les sociétés les concessions
autoroutières font beaucoup référence à
la qualité du travail de la RT ils n'ont
pas inventé les chiffres
il s'appuie d'ailleurs sur les résultats
sur les diagnostics qui ont été faits
évidemment ne manque pas de nous dire il
y a des investissements à faire
mais dans l'approche du sujet qui dit
envisager de nouveaux investissements ça
appellerait presque automatiquement
mieux qu'une prorogation des contrats
rallongement de la durée des contacts
concessions vous voyez le genre de
dialectique dans laquelle on est
c'est-à-dire que d'un côté on a besoin
d'investir et en même temps il nous
semble prudent de recommander une
nouvelle écriture des contrats enfin moi
il me semble que
ça me paraît complètement complètement
utile et donc voilà alors évidemment le
ministre de maire a dit des choses
en tout cas j'en tire comme enseignement
qui vaut mieux être bon en mathématiques
et en écriture de contrat ça c'est je
pense respecter absolument ce qu'il a
dit
[Musique]
mais dans la perspective d'une nouvelle
réécriture est-ce que vous avez quelle
idée sur la méthode qui pourrait être
employée à la fois pour ne pas attendre
2031 2036
et en même temps quels sont les marges
de manœuvre possible dans le cadre
contrainte actuel c'est un peu la
complexité du sujet telle que moi je la
perçois merci merci je vais dans la
parole à Jacques ternic
et merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président remonte encore vous appelez
président parce que vos six ans à la
tête de la RT donc qui s'inscrivent
C'est vous qui le dites dans un acte 1
de la régulation des transports avec des
avancées décisives partant du
ferroviaire grands aéroports autocars
autoroute transports publics urbain
francilien et les services numériques de
la mobilité je crois que j'ai rien
oublié donc les cibles je dirais de cet
acte 1 ça a été
évité les rangs de monopoles les
privilèges qui sera indus pour
l'opérateur historique l'opacité les
discriminations pour l'accès aux réseaux
aux données aux infrastructures
la question de la tarification des
péages d'une éventuelle sur rentabilité
des concessionnaires disproportionnées
au regard des investissements donc cet
acte 1 que vous avez conduit qui est
l'approfondissement pour le conforter
nécessite-t-il à votre sens alors les
les valeurs les exigences de la RT
dialogue expertise transparence et vous
avez fortement insisté indépendance qui
sous-tendent l'action de la RT donc
comment qu'est-ce que vous attendez en
clair du Parlement pour conforter la RT
j'ai vu que par exemple vous évoquez
évolution d'un avis simple la vie simple
vers un avis conforme l'acte 2 que vous
évoquez donc qui est devant nous peut
pas être le simple prolongement c'est
l'objet de mes trois questions donc sur
l'essor du ferroviaire annoncé le New
Deal du ferroviaire donc vous avez
sévèrement jugé vous venez de le dire le
contrat de performance et celle-ci
réseau la donne semble avoir changé avec
le rapport du coi le discours des bornes
et les dizaines de milliards annoncés
quel rôle peut jouer la RT vous l'avez
déjà en partie évoquée dans le débat et
l'élaboration de la programmation pour
qu'elle soit cohérente de la
régénération la modernisation
ferroviaire
l'avènement des réseaux Express même
propolitain et le frais de ferroviaire
qui doit être doublé à l'horizon 2030
sur l'autoroute
si l'appareil qu'effectivement
l'équilibre financier des concessions et
globalement atteint dès maintenant et
qu'elles vont encore dégager quelques
dizaines de milliards de profits
d'ici
l'issue des concessions actuelles
comment réguler le partage de ces
milliards entre l'État et ses besoins
d'investissement dans les reports modaux
les usagers et puis un petit peu les
actionnaires comment aussi préparer la
baisse de rendement de ce que rapporte
des autoroutes et globalement le
transport routier annoncé avec la TICPE
qui va perdre de la consistance avec la
décarbonation et puis
inévitablement la fin des concessions
qui sont assises sur des investissements
qui étaient massifs
quel que soit qu'elle soit ce qui
succède le COI je parle de la
perspective d'une perte de recettes qui
soit de l'ordre de 50 à 70% au regard
des règles européennes d'aujourd'hui
ça risque de favoriser dans les
décennies à venir un mode qui nous
faudrait au contraire réduire en fin
dernière question c'est acte 2 pour le
COI son scénario il l'appelle la
planification écologique est-ce que ce
n'est pas aussi une façon de mettre dans
l'émission de la RT une vraie régulation
écologique et qu'elle pourrait être
ses contours
dès la parole à papier
merci monsieur le président
je vais essayer de monter la mayonnaise
Bernard romain je me réjouis de cette
invitation et de et de vous retrouver
pour évoquer l'ensemble des sujets pas
que les sujets autoroutiers bien sûr et
j'en dirai un mot par rapport à notre
actualité au sein de la commission moi
je suis ravi du travail qu'on a pu
accomplir un accomplir ensemble fringant
sénateur de droite du Sud je ne pensais
jamais pouvoir travailler avec un ancien
député de gauche du Nord
mais par votre force de travail par
votre compétence et par votre
indépendance qui est le maître mot qui
est la base du job on a réussi et j'irai
votre courage également pour la question
de et le sujet de l'ouverture à la
concurrence nous avons pu très bien
travailler ensemble à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui
Bernard romain et fait un travail
tellement efficace qu'il est devenu
remplaçable
il semble que vous chers collègues vous
aussi vous avez votre part de
responsabilité il semble que vous
fassiez peur au putatif candidat dans le
cadre de l'article 13 puisque bientôt
une année que vous n'êtes pas remplacé
et que quelques candidatures ont été
entendus certaines ont même été jusqu'au
perron du Sénat et se sont rétractés la
veille au soir en tout cas il est
important qu'on puisse rapidement à la
fois pour l'autorité organisateur
l'autorité administrative indépendante
et pour le monde du transport en général
vous trouvez enfin un remplaçant et je
l'espère de de qualité comme vous l'été
moi ma première question
concerne ce sujet quel profil pour vous
remplacer
d'un côté le ministre bonne dit qu'il
faut plus de moyens et on est heureux de
l'entendre sur la RT par rapport à ses
missions et d'un autre côté chaque année
au PLF il donne un avis défavorable à
nos demandes de moyens supplémentaires
pour fonctionner pour voir rendre vos
avis vos rapports et puis surtout pour
vous garantir une indépendance totale
dans le cadre de potentiel
contentieux comme on en a souvent parlé
il semble même que le Président de la
République alors je connais pas
suffisamment il y en a peut-être
d'autres qui connaissent beaucoup mieux
que moi ici préfère les conventions
citoyennes aux autorités
organiques administratives indépendante
de là à les remettre en cause la
question peut se poser en tout cas pour
nous elle se pose pas vous avez rappelé
les liens forts qui unit le Sénat
maintenant
la RT
moi j'aimerais rapidement aborder trois
sujets
qui sont peut-être pas pour un en tout
cas de la compétence directe de la RT
mais qui est dans mon actualité dans
notre actualité
votre expertise personnelle est
importante que pensez-vous de la montée
en puissance des zones affaiblissement
issues de la loi d'orientation des
mobilités de climat et résilience de
l'acceptabilité sociale économique de
l'accompagnement et est-ce que c'est le
bon et seulement pour baisser les
émissions
au niveau des transports qui sont les
émissions vous le savez très bien qu'il
ne baisse pas depuis un certain temps
maintenant concernant le ferroviaire un
sujet qui nous a souvent réunis on a
longtemps plaidé pour plus de moyens et
notamment par rapport à
ces contrats de sous-performance qu'on a
eu à nous présenter pendant un certain
nombre d'années
très peu de moyens donnés pour la
régénération et pratiquement rien pour
la modernisation
que pensez-vous donc du rapport du
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures qu'on apportait avec un
certain nombre de collègues ici présents
et surtout des engagements de la
ministre board ces engagements forts
est-ce que vous pensez
que ce sera suivi des faits où vous
pensez que c'est un coup politique
comment vous voyez le financement des 75
milliards autres qui ne sont pas la
partie que l'État s'est engagée à amener
la question de l'augmentation des pH
ferroviaires que vous avez régulièrement
laissé passer est-ce que vous la jugez
définitivement inéluctable dans le mode
d'organisation du ferroviaire en France
et croyez-vous que la Société du Grand
Paris peut sauver SNCF à remplir ses
missions est-ce que vous le vivez plutôt
comme une mise sous tutelle ou comme une
aide providentielle en fin de mots sur
les questions autoroutières qui qui nous
réunissent également en ce moment et où
les collègues se sont largement exprimés
juste vous dire
on a semblé notamment la semaine
dernière que votre rapport tombait
vraiment un point nommé pour les
concessionnaires qui sont devenus archi
fan de la RT
pourquoi avez-vous une telle disparité
vous avez quand même évoqué déjà le
sujet entre vos conclusions et celles du
rapport de la haie ou du rapport de
l'IGF par le ton vraiment de la même
chose il semble que non d'après votre
première réponse donc on a envie de vous
entendre également sur sur ce sujet qui
qui occupe
l'excellent travail de notre excellente
commission
je te donne la parole
merci président c'était absolument
passionnant et j'ai deux affirmations et
trois questions à Bernard romans la
première affirmation c'est féliciter
d'avoir fait venir Bernard Roman alors
qu'il n'a plus de fonction politique on
savait déjà que c'était un homme libre
il vient d'en refaire la démonstration
c'était super intéressant
la deuxième affirmation c'est sur votre
indépendance je tiens à rappeler à mes
collègues que quand il a été nommé il y
avait un vent de suspicion très fort vu
sa proximité de relation avec le
président de la République et à l'époque
c'était passé de justesse en disant
maintenant il sera jamais indépendant le
gala et il a fait une preuve
d'indépendance plus que remarquable il a
refait aujourd'hui mais il l'a refait
tout au long de son mandat je pense
encore au sketch du contournement de
Montpellier aussi où il y avait eu un
bras de fer très fort entre le
régulateur et le ministre des Transports
voilà alors mes trois questions
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on écoute un
mathématicien parce que je suis perdu
maintenant entre le tri projet les tri
actionnaires et l'audition de notre
collègue de La Haye est extrêmement
intéressant et
monsieur le Président
les travaux de la de Fortin ont été
salués dans le rapport de l'IGF il y a
quelques lignes qui valident leurs
travaux et donc la démarche effectuée et
alors je vais reprendre la question du
tri actionnaire ou projet autrement
Vincent delay affirmé la semaine
dernière que d'ici à la fin des contrats
et vu leur modèle économique actuel il y
avait une marge de manœuvre de 30 à 35
milliards jusqu'à la fin des contrats
pour effectuer des travaux sans
augmenter le prix des des péages et
alors quel est qu'en pensez-vous
deuxième question j'ai commis une
proposition de résolution qui s'appelle
route de France dans laquelle je décris
de nouveaux contrats qui serait bien sûr
plus court mais et en plus dépourvu du
risque trafic quel est votre regard sur
des contrats de ce type et je m'inspire
d'une concession française peu connue
celle de Léonore par Abertis en banlieue
de Lyon où il n'y a pas la prise en
compte du risque trafic dans le contrat
de concession et la dernière question
vous a déjà été posée mais c'est un
président libéré que je la repose tous
les ans on demande une augmentation des
moyens de la RT et alors je reprends la
question de Philippe Tabarro combien
faudrait-il le moyen en plus merci
monsieur le Président je vous en prie
pour cette série de questions oui
beaucoup de questions qui me permettront
pas d'aller au fond sur sur certaines et
qui il y en a certaines sur lesquels je
m'excuserai mais je ne serai pas en
mesure de répondre sur les édefe par
exemple
à l'habitude de me poser des colles donc
Michel gilet pendant l'ordre Michel
Dagbert
évoque la question de l'utilisation des
profits pour financer d'autres modes
ferroviaires moi je suis 1000 fois pour
je suis 1000 fois pour si on détermine
des marges de manœuvre
au-delà des théories contractualisés
dans les contrats et je suis même pour
qu'on le prévoit avant que la route
puisse financer l'ensemble des autres
transferts des autres modes de transport
je dois dire sur ce point que je suis
venu ici une fois en audition
sur une proposition de loi mais vous
avez eu à vous prononcer plusieurs fois
sur ces questions de relationner les
propositions de relationnalisation des
sociétés d'autoroute et derrière
lesquels il y avait l'idée de péage
gratuit
l'un quel que soit le mode
de gestion choisie pour l'avenir qu'il
s'agisse de concession qu'il s'agisse de
régime qu'il s'agisse de
partenariats publics privés différents
je pense que le principe du pH est un
principe d'usagers payeur et que c'est
quelque chose qui est essentiel dans
l'évolution des transports dans notre
pays
on dit souvent
que
l'État doit se concentrer sur ces
missions
essentielles régaliennes
il faut s'interroger y compris en
prenant en compte la dimension
écologique a été évoquée par beaucoup
d'entre vous si la notion d'usagée
payeur
n'est pas la plus pertinente en ce qui
concerne pas seulement les autoroutes
mais en ce qui concerne le réseau
routier
je dois dire par ailleurs que lorsque je
n'ai pas le chiffre précis et je n'ai
pas voulu le solliciter en demandant
mais vous pourriez le demander aux
sociétés d'autorouties compris à
Monsieur nourri pour APRR que vous voyez
après quelle est la part de
PL de poids lourds étrangers
qui circulent sur les autoroutes
françaises
moi je veux bien que on dise plus de
péage et que ce soit la fiscalité
française qui paye
les
externalités pour faire passer des poids
lourds étrangers mais quand même le
principe de l'usager payeur est quand
même un bon principe
la transition écologique c'est
le dirai pas pour tout le monde puisque
cette question est récurrente mais
c'est naturellement l'une des questions
centrales qui doit être au cœur de la
réflexion sur les futurs contrastes il y
a de futurs contrats
les stations de rechargement les
parkings de dissuasion à l'entrée des
métropoles
les plateformes multimodales
en marge des des autoroutes à la fois
pour les passagers véhicules légers et
pour les poids lourds
les
poids lourds le transport des poids
lourds en sachant qu'il faut toujours
qu'on est en tête quelque chose qui est
essentiel c'est que dans le transport de
marchandises par la route
c'est
70% sur la route
c'est 30% par la route 70% dans les 10
derniers kilomètres
toujours avoir ça en tête on voit tout
le temps une multitude de camions sur
l'autoroute ça n'est que 30% du
transport des marchandises 70% c'est les
10 derniers kilomètres et donc faut
aussi avoir ça en tête pour prendre les
bonnes mesures mais c'est quelque chose
qui est essentiel pour la suite monsieur
laelec peut attendre 2031 2036 alors que
la décarbonation frappe à la porte non
et je veux vous dire quelque chose qui
me semble essentiel que je n'ai pas dit
je vous le dis avec avec force
il ne faudrait pas que la discussion sur
Conseil d'État l'aspect juridique
la fin des concessions est-ce qu'il faut
trop d'argent est-ce qu'il faut pas trop
réduire il ne faudrait pas que ce débat
qui est important
cache l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est que
dans 8 ans prend fin la première
concession
5 ans plus tard 90% du réseau les
concessions se terminent le chantier
essentiel sur lesquels il faut se mettre
maintenant mais moi je l'ai dit pendant
6 ans au gouvernement c'est la fin des
concessions
dans les contrats les concessionnaires
doivent remettre en bon état
et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire le bon
état on en sait toujours rien on en sait
toujours rien mais dans les contrats il
est prévu que 7 ans avant la termes des
contrastes c'est-à-dire l'année
prochaine pour SANEF et sa PN
on doit faire la feuille de route de ce
qui reste à faire pour entendre en bon
état les milliards d'investissements qui
seront nécessaires pour que les sociétés
remettent en bon état à l'état à la fin
des concessions c'est la première chose
puis la deuxième chose c'est que dans
les contrats il y avait des opérations
qui étaient prévues
et certaines n'ont pas été faites donc
il faut revisiter tous les contrats pour
savoir quels sont les opérations qui
étaient prévues et qui n'ont pas été
faites
et puis la troisième chose c'est qu'il
faut préparer de nouveaux contrats s'il
y a de nouvelles concessions pour faire
un cahier des charges
au-delà de la durée de
[Musique]
la géographie des contrats pour faire un
cahier des charges il faut avoir une
vision extrêmement fine extrêmement
précise des secteurs qui vont être
concédés
des travaux qui seront à faire de
l'évaluation de ces travaux pour les
mettre dans les contrats c'est trois ans
de boulot ces trois ans de boulot et
puis après sur la mise en concurrence
ces deux ans de procédure ça veut dire
que on est
à -8 et on sait qu'à moins 5 faut être
prêt à partir
il reste rien si l'État ne concentre pas
tous ces efforts pour faire ça on va se
retrouver le bec dans l'eau à la fin des
concessions et donc c'est quelque chose
qui est deuxième chose qui est
importante
monsieur Fernique quelle
approfondissement pour l'acte 2 avis
simple à vie conforme oui je pense que
je pense que le rôle de régulateur si le
Parlement choisi un modèle concessif ou
un modèle nouveau public privé c'est à
dire s'ils ne choisit pas la régie
puisque la régie ça change de dimension
c'est effectivement de passer de la vie
simple à la vie conforme sur un certain
nombre de questions
liées aux avenants
en aucun cas l'opportunité je veux dire
que on prend le contournement de
Montpellier nous on a donné un avis qui
était un avis très réservé sur mais pas
sur le principe moi j'ai eu le maire de
Montpellier au téléphone en toute
indépendant je lui ai dit mais je
pouvais ça aussi je pouvais l'avoir au
téléphone parce qu'il savait que j'étais
indépendant et je pouvais l'appeler
parce que je savais que quel que soit le
coup de téléphone la nature du coup de
téléphone je prendrai la décision en
fonction des critères qui étaient ceux
de la RT on a eu un avis négatif sur
l'aéroport pas négatif en fait ce qui
proposait un mode de financement
différent d'ailleurs que le Conseil
d'État conforté par la suite
le
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire là-dessus
oui
on a eu à cet avis s'il avait été
conforme le mode de financement aurait
été proposé différemment là il était
indicatif le considant dans la pacte du
compte donc oui je suis je suis pour ça
quel rôle pour l'avenir du ferroviaire
les 100 milliards
ça n'est pas alerté de veiller à ce que
c'est 100 milliards arrivent sur la
table et soit effectivement dépensé
comme le propose le le comité
d'orientation des investissements mais
la RTA un rôle de vigie c'est au
Parlement de le décider c'est au
Parlement de faire en sorte que ces 100
milliards arrivent effectivement comment
25 milliards
75,75 milliards le gouvernement compte
l'Europe naturellement et l'Europe sera
au rendez-vous sur des infrastructures
propres comptent sur les régions et là
ce sera aux régions de décider notamment
sur les RER métropolitains qui sont
indispensables je pense dans notre pays
j'étais moi-même partisan et acteurs
d'un RER métropolitain entre le bassin
minier et la métropole lilloise il y a
longtemps n'est-ce pas Madame filleul
et donc je suis heureux de voir c'est
aussi revenir à la surface
de la route pour pouvoir financer le
ferroviaire parce que c'est un des
parents mais c'était un des propositions
de la première ministre de dire la route
de financer de ferroviaire
si alors d'où la nécessité de travail
sur les contrats aujourd'hui
sur la durée des contrats sur la
géographie des contrats et sur ce qu'on
met dans les contrats sur ce qu'on met
sur ce qu'on ne met pas dans les
contrats
si on laisse les péages au niveau
auxquels ils sont aujourd'hui et moi je
ne proposerai pas de les baisser si
j'étais dans l'exécutif ou si j'étais
parlementaire si on les laisse au niveau
qui existe aujourd'hui et si on fait des
contrats qui font 20 ou 25 ans et qu'on
met comme obligation d'investissement
au futur concessionnaires ou aux futurs
structures publiques privées qui
géreront ces contrats un niveau
d'investissement qui permet de dégager
une marge supplémentaire si on ne leur
laisse pas tous les risques y compris le
risque trafic vous savez dans chaque
contrat il y a un risque trafic c'est à
dire on dit le trafic va augmenter de 1
et demi par an mais si l'augmente de 3%
le bénéfice il augmente il double
si ce risque par trafic est partagé s'il
y a une clause de revoyure avec les
concessionnaires en disant si vous
gagnez plus d'argent
c'est pas pour vous on partage et ce que
l'État mon père il le met sur le
ferroviaire c'est tout un dispositif
qu'il faut essayer d'imaginer qui est un
dispositif qui permettrait Infiné à la
route de contribuer au financement des
autres modes donc d'où le travail sur
les contrats qui est indispensable
aujourd'hui
j'essaye d'aller vite pour répondre à
tout le monde parce qu'il me reste
quelques minutes
monsieur table monsieur verdict j'ai
répondu
baisse le rendement de texte et ICPE je
peux pas vous dire
mais ça renvoie la question globale du
financement
mettre la régulation
écologique une dimension écologique on
s'est posé la question mais je l'évoque
en conclusion de mon bilan
on ne peut plus laisser le régulateur
indifférent aux questions de
développement durable
dans les transports c'est une évidence
dans l'aéroportuaire c'est une évidence
et donc il faut que on réfléchisse
collectivement à une manière de
permettre aux régulateur d'introduire
dans les critères qui sont les siens
cette donnée environnementale ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
monsieur Tabaro
j'espère j'oublie personne
monsieur Tabarro
quel profil pour le président
un despendances
indépendance c'était essentiel c'était
essentiel c'est toute la crédibilité de
la régulation des transports qui est en
cause
indépendance c'est vraiment le premier
critère rebondit quand même sur ce qu'a
dit Olivier en disant c'était passé
juste
ce ne savait pas passer juste mais
j'étais venu dans cette salle je crois
que j'avais une ascension
je pense oui ça n'était pas passé juste
mais Tabaro n'avait pas encore commencé
son mandat donc il n'était pas là mais
mais j'avais dû faire serment
d'indépendance et je me suis tenu
puisque c'est vrai que j'étais un ami
proche du président de la République à
l'époque et que je dois vous le dire je
n'ai jamais reçu un coup de fil d'un
président de la République le premier ou
le deuxième sur quelques dossiers que ce
soit même si je les savais très
intéressé sur ces dossiers donc
c'est indépendance c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel moyen
moyen moi j'en ai assez aussi
ce que j'ai vu ce dernier derrière mon
départ une nouvelle fois le ministre du
Budget
dire non à une augmentation des moyens
de la RT je vais vous dire donner ce
chiffre retenez-le
entre mon arrivée et mon départ plus 70%
de personnel
des experts
pas d'emploi de catégorie C à la RT des
très peu de baies 3 et que da et da+ des
polytechniciens des docteurs des en
économie des plus 70% de personnel et le
budget de la RT c'est
60 70 % du budget de la RT c'est le
personnel
en six ans plus 20% de l'augmentation de
nos ressources
plus 70% de personnels plus 20%
d'augmentation de nos ressources si on
veut tuer la régulation des transports
il faut continuer à ne pas donner les
moyens à l'autorité il y a pas une
autorité qui peut fonctionner
correctement
affirmer son indépendance si elle n'a
pas les moyens de son expertise et donc
les plus de 70% de personnel c'était pas
pour nous amuser c'est parce qu'on a eu
cinq secteurs supplémentaires de
régulation et qu'on a dû prendre au pied
levés d'ailleurs puisqu'on les a donnés
une fois trois mois avant de réguler sur
l'aéroportuaire on les a eu trois mois
avant de donner notre première décision
donc ça c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
monter les élèves je peux pas répondre
Philippe je suis désolé
sur le ferroviaire j'en ai dit beaucoup
[Musique]
sur les concessionnaires d'autoroute
j'essaye de simplifier les choses pour
tous ceux qui ne sont pas mathématiciens
je ne le suis pas non plus
que de quoi a besoin le Conseil d'État
pour statuer il a besoin mais c'est
Philippe Martin qui le disait lui-même
il a besoin de
chiffres de choses précises on dit pas
la rentabilité comme ça
la rentabilité depuis l'origine ou
depuis la privatisation
premièrement voir on pourrait ajouter un
troisième élément ou depuis la loi Sapin
puisque ça a changé aussi un certain
nombre de choses la rentabilité pour
l'ensemble des apporteurs de fonds
c'est-à-dire les actionnaires les
créanciers ou seulement pour les uns ou
pour les autres
Bruno Le Maire dit clairement c'est pour
les actionnaires qu'il l'a fait mais de
quoi a besoin de conseil d'État pour
juger pour délibérer et puis troisième
élément la rentabilité à date
à tel moment où la rentabilité projetée
sur la durée de la concession comme
c'est prévu dans les contrats et donc
ces trois éléments on ne les a pas à la
RT à moins qu'ils aient fait ce travail
depuis 6 mois mais on est capable de les
avoir rapidement parce qu'on a toutes
les données sur les expertises qu'on
achète et donc je ne comprends pas
vraiment je ne comprends pas que le
gouvernement ne fasse pas appel à
l'autorité qui a été mise en place pour
ça et qu'on s'appuie sur des études qui
sont certes qui ont qui ont toutes leurs
valeurs et d'ailleurs qui disent qu'elle
est leur valeur d'ailleurs Bruno Le
Maire dit lui-même dans son audition sur
le trip projet
on a à peu près les mêmes résultats que
ceux de la RT et en plus il
correspondent à peu près à ce qui était
prévu dans les contrats donc
si on veut que le Conseil d'État soit
saisi il faut le saisir avec tous les
éléments et d'ailleurs c'est ce que
risque de demander le Conseil d'État
j'ai répondu Philippe et puis Olivier
Jacquin Olivier Jacquin j'ai bien lu La
Tribune haute de France
ça c'est le Parlement qui décidera
l'exécutif qui proposera le Parlement
qui décidera
qu'est-ce qu'on veut pour la suite moi
ce qui me semble essentiel c'est que il
y a un pH et que le principe de l'usager
payeur soit maintenu la deuxième chose
sur laquelle il faudra s'interroger
c'est le périmètre
avec une difficulté ce qui a
trois gros que vous additionnez
d'ailleurs ça n'est fait sa PN ça se
termine
en 2031 et puis les autres se terminent
en 2036
est-ce qu'on peut avoir des positions
différentes entre le premier qui se
termine et les deux autres est-ce qu'il
faut essayer de rassembler l'ensemble en
modifiant des dates est-ce que
on choisit un système qui pourra
s'appliquer au premier au second mais
quel partenariat public privé
quel périmètre on prend est-ce qu'on y
inclus des morceaux d'autoroute qui n'y
sont pas aujourd'hui moi par exemple je
prends l'autoroute du Nord je peux vous
dire que je sais jusqu'à quel point
c'est la sanaf qui l'entretient parce
que derrière c'est plus du tout le même
entretien si on veut faire des parkings
de dissuasion à l'entrée de Paris sur le
Nord
il faut que il y ait une autoroute
concédée ou confiée en gestion à
quelques organismes que ce soit qui va
jusqu'au périphérique et non pas qu'il
s'arrête à 30 km de Paris pour pouvoir
faire les parkings de dissuasion au plus
proche de la capitale donc toutes ces
questions ce sont des questions qui va
falloir intégrer la géographie la durée
la durée ça peut être ça peut plus être
du 50 ou du 60 ans on ne sait pas
possible parce que quand on fait des
durées aussi longues forcément il y a
des problématiques nouvelles qui
apparaissent et il y a des avenants
nouveaux qui apparaissent quand il y a
des avenants nouveaux qui apparaissent
et ben il y a plus concurrence sur la
réalisation de ces avenants puis je vous
l'ai dit 17 avenant c'est 2 milliards
d'euros c'est pas rien quand même donc
ce sont des questions qui qu'il faut se
poser
le tri j'ai répondu
les chiffres évoqués par Bruno Le Maire
et par le rapport de la haie sont des
chiffres qui touchent à la même chose
c'est le théorie actionnaire est-ce que
c'est le théorie actionnaire qui vaut
je suis pas en position décidé mais si
le Conseil d'État est saisi où doit être
saisie il faut qu'il le soit avec tous
les éléments donc voilà et puis
transfert du risque
alors il y a le risque trafic
mais il y a aussi tous les autres
risques
et aujourd'hui
le choix qui a été celui du gouvernement
en 2006 lors de la privatisation
c'est de transférer tous les risques aux
concessionnaires dans les contrats c'est
la fin je termine le président
le risque trafic étant sans doute l'un
des plus importants puisque comme je
vous l'ai dit
c'est lorsque
on est sur un et demi de trois sites de
taux de graphique taux de trafic et
d'évolution proposée qu'on arrive à
trois c'est considérable en terme de de
levier
moi je suis beaucoup plus pour à la fois
des risques partagés et comme c'est le
cas dans des modèles
la RT depuis mon départ a publié le
rapport 2 et il y a des comparatifs
étrangers moi j'avais beaucoup travaillé
avec le régulateur italien
qui n'est pas un modèle en terme de
de collégialité puisque c'est le
président qui décide de tout
tandis que chez nous il y a un vrai
collège qui délibère et délibère après
des débats
argumentés
en Italie c'est plus un président avec
deux vices présidents c'est pas du tout
la même chose mais leur modèle sur les
autoroutes complètement modifié depuis
l'affaire du pont de gêne est un modèle
sur lequel on peut beaucoup s'inspirer
la clause de revoyure tous les cinq ans
avec une rediscution globale du
mécanisme financier qui repose sur les
péages
c'est
et la clause de revoyure qui
consisterait à dire les bénéfices que
vous faites entre autres on les récupère
pour les autres modes ou les bénéfices
que vous faites au-delà de ce qui était
prévu par le tri il est kif-kif parce
qu'on a partagé les riffs les risques à
kifkif à 55 ans ça me semble être des
bonnes solutions mais j'y ins
si on veut travailler sur la suite c'est
maintenant qu'il faut commencer c'est
maintenant qu'il faut commencer la liste
des opérations qui sont dans les
contrats et qui ne sont pas réalisés
elle pose question elle pose question
parce que l'écriture des contrats n'est
pas clair
sur le pays a 2016-2017
nous avons refusé neuf opérations qui
étaient proposées dans le plan
d'investissement par les sociétés
concessionnaires et par le gouvernement
dont on s'est rendu compte en épluchant
les contrats qu'elles étaient déjà dans
les contrats les sociétés
concessionnaires toutes on dit non non
c'est dans les contrats ça veut pas tout
à fait dire ça et c'est vrai qu'il y
avait une ambiguïté devant la position
de la RT le gouvernement les a retirés
c'est neuf opérations mais elles sont
toujours en l'air aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'elles étaient dans les contrats ou
est-ce qu'elles n'étaient pas dans les
contrats et quand c'est une aire de
stationnement ou un échangeur qui était
dans un contrat ou quand il ne l'était
pas c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
pour la suite et donc c'est quelque
chose
c'est un travail colossal pour la
préparation des cahiers des charges et
il faut vraiment qu'on s'y mette
immédiatement que le ministère des
Transports s'y met immédiatement
quant à ce sommet des autoroutes je
termine là-dessus vraiment
j'ai été j'étais scotchée quand j'ai lu
cette proposition c'est une déclaration
de Clément baume
voilà président
un grand merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président pour pour vos propos
liminaires et pour les réponses à les
réponses à nos questions réponses
claires précises qui nous trace un
chemin à suivre avec effectivement un
grand nombre de conseils judicieux et
puis effectivement on a bien compris
qu'il fallait qu'on regarde les choses
immédiatement si on veut être dans les
temps et puis effectivement que la RT
soit bien associé ce qui va se passer
merci et je tiens à remercier
l'ensemble de mes collègues qui vous ont
interrogé parce que chacune et chacun à
respecter son temps de parole voilà
merci merci Monsieur Merci